hey guys what's up this is andrew for
sentences.com
so in this video i would like to talk
about the cryptocurrency market guys
we're having some
nice breakouts on the bitcoin and dutch
coin and the ethereum
so a lot of things are happening some of
my friends are telling me bro it's not
going to hold
we're going to go lower lower we're
going to make one more dip so i want to
discuss all of this
see what are the different scenarios and
give you of course my preferred one
so let's get into it
[Music]
let's start with bitcoin guys it's been
long time i haven't done this
cryptocurrency
so i don't want to make it too long guys
i was making regular
updates on the bitcoin guys in my last
video i was telling you that
on the farmer's timeframe we were seeing
some nice bullish divergences guys here
all right pretty obvious market making
lower lows the macd going higher all
right
it's only true from here to here okay so
here we have this nice bullish
divergence
so this is usually impacting the price
this is a tip i'm giving you guys you're
not gonna find this anywhere in any book
this is my experience those kind of
divergences
are then gonna impact the price roughly
for the same period that the last
so roughly from here to here okay
so it's basically gonna stop impacting
the price
soon but it's still impacting the price
here so
it gave me the information that here we
would probably go higher and hold
it's not giving me the information that
we're gonna break 39 just
you know for you to understand how i use
those all right
let's do some eliot wave counting guys
the eliot wave counting is
perfect on the bitcoin it's absolutely
perfect
i'm not gonna go through this again guys
but look at my previous videos
i'm explaining very well how i do all
this counting so i know that this
may seem messy for you guys but i can
tell you
that this is so helpful to me here you
see the
this fifth wave for example when we went
to 65 was
so you know easy to trade i gave you
this trade guys
here we had the bearish divergence
market making higher highs
this ending diagonal you know with the
false wave entering wave 133
that was followed by breakout to re-test
and then we moved down i gave you
everything here
that's the reason why i'm going to keep
using android wave countings on the
bitcoin because you know whenever
something is working well
you need to keep using it that's the
golden rule of trading
okay and never stop using something that
is working
so here as i'm always saying guys when
something is messy it's probably
corrected look at this mess
okay look at that it's impossible to
label properly all right
i'm struggling here a lot so once again
the rule that i'm trying to apply
is to have abc or one two three four
five so this is to me
it could still be a one two three four
five let's be honest the force wave
could be very messy which is correct
which would make sense but i prefer this
leveling all right so abc
abc abcde maybe alright so this i
struggle here right this is not clean
let's be honest look at this
horrible triangle all right it's not a
triangle i don't know what it is but
i know that it's corrective and looks to
me like a w x
y alright so maybe the correction
is done it looks good to me because here
we're having this breakout
so i told you guys to watch for this for
this area guys
all right and we had here the breakout
on the 24th
of july and since then we are moving
higher so this is
kind of expected we found some
resistance
guys no surprise you connect the high
here
okay i'm not looking at the market i'm
just doing my stuff
here all right let's make it
tighter bam i'm connecting here this
high
okay and you see guys
perfectly on it perfectly on it so those
that telling me that technical analysis
doesn't work on bitcoin you just have
the proof that it does right doesn't
mean that it will always give good
signals of course this is a very
manipulated market
a lot of weights are here by the way so
i'm working with
other traders right now i'm kind of
building a team
uh we're gonna animate some chats on
discord we're gonna have some portfolios
that are gonna be managed by us we're
gonna show you everything we do guys and
one of the traders in the team here was
explaining to me this morning that this
is probably a cleanup
made by the whales so they clean short
positions
all right so they all bite together to
clean the beds
and once the bears are wiped out then
usually they're not gonna try to put
pressure here so this is just a
technique that is used
for him there's going to be one motif so
it's interesting my analysis is slightly
different to me this is very bullish
i see that we have complete the
correction
potentially this is complete this looks
like something that is complete
so nothing guaranteed of course but it
looks complete to me for me we are
moving
higher so for now we only have three
waves right one two
three so i expect a four that we're
doing right now and i expect a fifth
that is going gonna break that all right
and then we're gonna have this
and this is the scenario i'm having guys
for a very long time all right
very long time you can check my videos
i'm calling this scenario for very long
time
it's finally happening so what can you
do here
if you are longer perfect just keep it
no financial advice of course this is
only what i would do
if i have no long position here i would
buy the retest
you know of the breakout around 33 with
the moving averages
you know all this area is going to be a
buying area between 35 and 33
and 32.5 all right all this area is a
very nice area to buy
if we have the breakout right away so
here as well 36 but i think 36 is a bit
high
all right so let's see maybe this is
gonna be the way we rebound
i have no clue guys you need to see on
the shorter term but all this area is
gonna be supporting the price and if we
break
of course guys you can enter on this
retest all right
so we're gonna have one more re-test so
maybe it's gonna be like this i don't
know
all right so either we're gonna retest
this streamline or we're gonna retest
lower so don't panic
all right you're gonna have one more
entry level mid-august
if we break out everything so easy relax
all right
next one dutch coin guys you can see
that those are moving together
so i'm mostly focused on bitcoin because
bitcoin is the king is leading the way
for the other cryptocurrencies but here
guys same thing
nice breakout i gave you this guys on my
discord as well
we have a nice breakout with 22 being
the resistance level
because it's the support level here it
was the resistance level as well here
as well here many reaction and we have
the 200 period on the first time frame
that is coming here
so 22 is the resistance level don't buy
here guys
it's not a nice level to buy if we come
back to
0.18 this is a nice level to buy all
right and if we work 22 there's gonna be
a re-test
so either you wait and you buy the
retest or you wait to throw pullback all
right don't buy
here and then we probably gonna move
higher following the bitcoin so bitcoin
is the one to follow
ethereum this is even a more beautiful
situation the breakout just occurred
guys
so here on the hourly timeframe let's
zoom zoom out a bit
okay because you see on the bitcoin the
breakout is
20 higher on the dutch coin the breakout
is 20 higher and then the ethereum
the breakout is
eight percent higher so this is a nice
opportunity all right the ethereum is
not following
that strong yet i'm gonna try to post
this as soon as possible guys
but the ethereum is still nice to buy
all right
and of course expect if the breakout is
confirmed expect
uh retest guys bam bam and then we move
higher so this is also a nice area to
enter a long position
of course there are some alternative
scenarios that go lower so guys
if bitcoin is trading below 33 probably
the buyers are not ready yet all right
and probably we're gonna have one more
dip
33 is for me the level we bitcoin needs
to hold for all of these
scenarios to be correct so that's it for
me i hope you guys enjoyed this video
and if you did please don't forget to
click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore see you guys